he's just rolling sideways on the train
how the heck did they paint him out of
that shot oh yes I do if I have one
critique what's the one what's the one
read thanks to Rome for sponsoring this
video
stick around to the end to see how you
can get a discount on your first
purchase guys welcome back to another
very exciting episodes of VFX artist
react and guys today is very special
because it's Bollywood 3 we are filming
this episode on the brink of quarantine
that's right guys we're renaming this
channel 2 through we're going out on a
limb for you guys we're sitting sick
less than 6 inches apart from each other
just for you we're gonna be watching
some great stuff here today this is
Bollywood guys not only not only is this
Bollywood it's Hollywood
do all you would in Hollywood all the
woods jollywood real I think so
so regardless guys stay healthy stay
safe and let's enjoy some Bollywood
clips here yeah
[Music]
oh there's the fly here is to fly do I
wonder oh my goodness is the flag gonna
kick his butt or that fly's gonna turn
the needle up and he's gonna stab
something he's gonna flip he's gonna
flip this dude he's gonna kill her with
a bare feet bonito up
[Music]
oh my glasses fly is gonna matrix top
some what is dude now just here like
training we just killed the power at
that but of course of course I think I
had that toy as a kid spy gear night
goggles see seven meters away in the
dark with high-tech spy here spy like a
pro oh my god is he shooting at shotgun
don't make me blow up my favorite
figurine
look at all these phantom shots though I
mean this is pretty cool some pretty
cool slow-mo mccannon they set it up did
they set it up yeah coughs cannon
ooh that's a last one that was that was
a dust wave that should not have been as
transparent as it was that's the problem
when you're trying to composite like
dust and smoke is that you might be
tempted just to lower the opacity to
make it more transparent but if you have
a big smoke plume its opaque and what
they're using here is one of those big
volumetric smoke things and it should be
opaque but they've lowered the
transparency so that you can see through
it and see the thing actually falling
but you know what I bet you some guy did
that shot in a couple hours yeah usually
when an effect starts looking kind of
weak like that it's because they didn't
have much time to do it
I really wish more Hollywood movies had
done effects like this like goods like
practical like tons of explosives tons
of sparks it's well done
[Applause]
let's come what's it gonna do what's it
gonna do okay what's the plan on this
[Music]
Plan B don't underestimate this fly oh
my god he had so many plans we can't see
which is the real we can enter the
dragon
[Music]
what just the CG is like so obviously CG
but I don't care
oh he's gonna launch himself is that
gunpowder he's gonna sacrifice himself
he knows what he knows what the doofus
the set the ultimate sacrifice oh my
goodness
dudes like eyes are shutting
[Music]
oh my goodness he's a fly
dude good job fly movie it's gonna go
into like a locket she's gonna keep it
forever put it in your locket she lock
it oh yes yes here's the thing I think
we're all in agreeance this is
incredible this is like one of the
greatest things ever yeah honestly I
didn't think the animation was that bad
it did what it was trying to do I feel
like the motion blur is kind of all over
the place there are a lot of shots where
there's no motion blur like look at the
leg right there you see the leg move
it's just like snaps into place there's
also the whole depth-of-field thing when
you're filming stuff that's small like
your depth of field is very very short
very shallow yeah and the entirety of
the fly is in focus where like like you
say the depth of field should be just a
part of the fly and that's actually
something they did really well on the
movie ant-man yeah the CG rendering
aside their shot selection is actually
really good literally an animator had to
sit there like how do I communicate that
this fly is struggling to save this
woman like with fly body language and
they did it they did it like that stuff
is really really cool and that's that's
artistry right there that's a true
artistry if you found the corners of
your mouth curl up into a smile while
watching this video then please
subscribe we do this like every week so
in the last bollywood episode we talked
about a movie called zero which had some
effects that kind of blew our minds not
kind of do believe actually Dorma yeah I
had to go scoop up my brains and come
back in yeah well the VFX house that
actually did those effects saw the
episode and they ended up actually
releasing a bigger breakdown for that
show
this this is a movie about a low person
who is very well-off and they're trying
to find themselves he's actually 5/7 and
in the movie he's four eight but that
doesn't make sense though like what but
how is he like it's not just him being
shorter he's like scaled they scaler
hands back up you saw her see like this
is frame by frame Photoshop manipulation
style stuff for that it hurts so bad
doesn't this hurt look at those arms
look at that breaking they readjusted
those guys arms they have some people
that really understand human anatomy
working on this team just straight
things but to shrink them correctly like
are they using for that I think they're
using all the takes in different pieces
of it so it's like they're able to merge
different parts of each take together
[Music]
they put cg feet on him yes yes what
those legs look photo-real when you're
painting something out and you have a
hand sized hole that you need to replace
you need that information okay
how the heck do they paint them out of
that shot what it's like you're showing
your cards right now but your cards are
so high level that it still hurts my
head it's like showing me a magic trick
it's like the solution is actual magic
like that right there they have to
replace all of his hair
so that's interacting with the bird here
that's a CG bird I guess it makes sense
man it's a really good looking CG bird
this is insane
yeah like the amount of work going into
this just make a dude short and
meanwhile there's short actors out there
be like what the hell done that before
with Curious Case of Benjamin Button
it's kind of the similar way I mean the
case parts maybe the agent reversed but
my point is that it required a lot of
detailed photo realistic effects on an
actor to make them completely not who
they were the industry they approve
projects based on who the lead actor is
I think your point is valid because
there's all of this effort going in when
it's like the easier and far cheaper
route would just be to cast a smaller
actor I do if I have one critique what's
the one what's the one read it's that
final splashdown in the water oh god I
think the waters like the DD DD the
water just goes Kabam out of there you
are kind of right once again hats off to
the red chillies VFX team we're still
blown away all you've done is impress us
more like my jaw was here and then now
it's like we had to like sew it back in
so Shahrukh Khan is very very famous
actor in India we got a lot of comments
from you guys asking about raw 1 which
also stars Shahrukh Oh does it alright
so let's take a look
[Music]
oh that was cool okay cool I mean this
is Bollywood it's not like we're looking
at inertia or physics in this true
looks like CG CG CG trained to act as
the wall
he's like jumping onto the actual
platform but with like a crash pad down
below it looks like the camera continues
out on a dolly and that's a hidden cut
right there to a new element to him just
sleeping mm-hmm looks like green-screen
that's probably all full CG at that
point the Train on the left is CG the
Train on the right is real it's a plate
of pushing it on the Train on the right
a green-screen element of the guy
jumping and then a CD train on the Left
continuing along its own train tracks
don't try this at home who is this man
what were they doing what were they
doing like that looks like it might be
real like they might have to do two on a
wire you just running sideways on the
train why you easy to do that book he
had to power up his meter before he
could use it that makes the most sense
actually buddy look at progress it isn't
Oh hands magic powers of course
[Music]
she looks very sure of herself she
doesn't look so sure of herself now the
icy hot headache
[Music]
oh is it gonna come busting through here
we go yes yeah this isn't cracks those
are those are pretty decent cracks
showing up though yeah the dust falling
out yeah where's that train yeah there
it is
give me that train be solid CG my lab is
out there Oh taxi that just got hit that
was a very real looking taxi apart from
the animation
man those VFX sure look sharp you know
what also looks sharp Bren
you're sure oh thanks Nico so this is
from our sponsor today rone and they
make something for the modern man
regardless of the occasion so all my
other dress shirts have one thing in
common in that they're not like
comfortable and stretchy like this like
look at this you ready ready dude I want
a sweet shirt like that that's yeah sure
- well you guys are both in luck no but
like for real though open them up and
see how stretchy they are they're
breathable too
wow that is really stretchy yeah it's
almost like a workout dress shirt I mean
it is they're commuter collection runs
commuter collection is the performance
alternative to the everyday work where
everything from pants to pullo's shorts
and shirts are lightweight comfortable
and wrinkle free it makes up
specifically for you know the office or
you know long flights in anything that's
nice but also very comfortable I can
already vouch super comfy so while these
guys are actually changing you can get
your own shirt by going to Rome comm
slash corridor crew and by using the
promo code porter crew to get 20% off
your first purchase what do you think
guys
this is you know I used to have a rule
don't put a pair of pants on me unless
they stretch unless I can do like the
splits in them
I think the same is true for the shirts
now so feeling pretty good anyway guys
link in the description check it all out
thank you for watching today's bollywood
episode number three I'm sure we'll have
another fourth one if you leave enough
comments suggesting things for us to
look at also check out our midweek
videos we talked about our life during
the course dude I put a nerf gun on a
drone stay safe out there guys stay
healthy and honestly you guys can
probably catch up on a whole bunch of
good movies that you've never seen
before I've seen a lot of great you know
I need someone to tally up all the
movies that we watch in a video that
Clint has not seen tally it up as a
total I can tally it up right now it's
all the Avengers movies it's all the
Marvel movies besides the early Iron
Man's I'm not gonna say what movie Dean
hasn't seen because it's gonna embarrass
him completely I'm just saying you know
all of us haven't seen some good movies
okay